-Welcome back. Congrats on this.
I want to get into all
this stuff.
But first of all,
I want to know,
how are you liking
New York City?
-I'm loving it.
I always knew I wanted to live
in New York since I was
a little kid.
-You did?
-Living here has been --
it's actually a dream.
It's been amazing.
-And you have your apartment.
What's the situation?
-Yeah, I fully moved here
I guess
a couple months ago officially.
But I came with my cat, Dolly.
I take her on walks
around the neighborhood.
-How is Dolly?
Is she enjoying the city?
-She's adapting. She used to go
outside a lot on my patio.
So, now I like to bring her
outside in a different way
because it's --
She's adapting to city life.
-Well, how do you bring her out?
The cat would escape.
-I got this little -- it's
almost like a suitcase,
but it's clear and she sits in
there and goes around the block.
-She looks like she's having
a great time.
[ Laughter ]
Can you zoom in on Dolly?
Uh, wow!
That is an unbelievable
invention.
Never heard of that.
-Yeah.
I honestly think she doesn't
hate it.
She seems to like it. Otherwise
I wouldn't bring her out in it.
-She seems to like it?
-She's just looking around.
[ Laughter ]
-She doesn't look happy at all.
-Does she look pissed?
-That's so funny.
I want to talk about
"Little Shop of Horrors,"
one of my favorite musicals.
And I got to know -- you were
telling me that you were
a musical theater nerd kid
when you were growing up.
-Yes, I was.
-I have a picture of you.
Explain this. How cute.
-Okay.
-You're nine?
-This is me at "Rent."
[ Audience awws ]
-Okay.
-I don't remember exactly what
this production was but
Anthony Rapp and Adam Pascal,
the original cast members,
were doing the show.
I was a die-hard "Rent" fan at
such a young age.
-Isn't it a little older --
-Yes, I don't know why my dad
really took me to the show.
I was like, "Do you think they
thought that was weird?"
Yeah.
-You just love the music?
-I love the music.
I kind of snuck away.
My cousin was babysitting me.
But I didn't know anything about
the show.
I think I may have
just seen the disc,
and I watched it, and he didn't
stop me.
-Did you understand what you
were watching?
-Not at all. No. Not at all.
-I have another picture that
you brought,
and this is a Halloween parade.
And you were dressed -- you were
dressed as Mimi from "Rent."
[ Laughter ]
-In, like, third grade.
-This is third grade.
Can you explain to everyone what
Mimi's character in "rent"?
-Um, well, yeah, Mimi
is an exotic dancer.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, she is. Yeah.
Did you know what that was?
Did you just think she danced
in exotic places?
-I don't know what my parents
were thinking
because they did let me go
like that.
And my mom must have helped me
gather the costume.
So, yeah.
-Well, now here you are.
You're starring as Audrey in
"Little Shop of Horrors."
This is fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You started the show a couple
weeks ago, right?
How have the shows been
going so far?
-They've been great.
I have really bad stage fright,
obviously.
You can probably tell because
I'm freaking out right now.
-No, you can't tell at all.
-Mm. But I was so, so nervous
for the first show.
And then I did it in front of
the audience and I was kind of
relieved and felt good about
everything.
And then the second show, I
think I got a little cocky
and I sort of just, like -- I
was getting ready to
go on stage,
and I just walked on.
And my first line in the show,
it's, "Good morning,
Mr. Mushnik."
And it just completely slipped
my mind.
But, like, in a musical,
it doesn't stop moving.
So I just sort of, like,
said, like...
[ Laughter ]
-That's your opening line?
-And then I was sweating.
It derailed my entire show.
-But now you're doing double --
you're doing on the weekends.
-Yeah, but I can't get cocky.
I learned my lesson.
-How many shows do you do
a week?
-Eight.
-Gosh.
-Yeah.
-It's a lot of work.
-But it's so fun.
I'm having the best time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I saw on the socials that
a lot of famous people
are going to see you.
Does it freak you out when
a famous person is
in the audience?
-Um, no.
They kind of keep asking,
though, like,
"Do you want us to tell you
if someone's here?"
-Do you want people to tell you?
-Yes.
Because the theater is small,
and you can see everyone.
So if someone randomly appeared
in the audience,
I think it would throw me if I
didn't know she was coming.
-So you would just stare at
Kate Hudson the whole show?
-Yeah, yeah.
-No one has freaked you out?
Kate Hudson you're fine with?
-Well, my favorite TV show is
"Catfish" on MTV.
-Of course.
-I've watched every episode
multiple times.
-Nev?
-Nev from "Catfish" came,
and he came --
-He's the one that freaked you
out?
-I was freaking out that he came
and then he came back again
with his kids and he was sitting
in the second row.
And I was -- Yeah, I was dying.
-That's the celebrity you were
like, "Oh, my gosh"?
-Yeah. I was not well.
-Wow.
-I was so excited.
-Who is the actor that does
the voice of Audrey II?
-Oh, Aaron Harrington.
-It's his birthday today.
-I saw that 'cause he was
excited that you were
on the show tonight.
He's fantastic in the show.
-He's incredible.
-Can we explain the show
for anyone
who hasn't seen
"Little Shop of Horrors"?
-Yeah. It's about a guy
who works at a flower shop on
Skid Row.
And he finds this plant,
a fly trap.
But we're not sure exactly
what it is.
And the only way it can grow
is by eating humans.
-Yeah, yeah. It needs blood.
-See, that's terrible.
It's not a great sell.
-No, no. That's great.
-How would you say it?
-That's exactly right. Yeah.
It's like a fly trap but --
-A man-eating plant.
-Yeah, it likes blood and then
starts eating humans
and starts eating everything and
grows to be giant and massive.
-And it sort of destroys
its life.
-Yes. But this is --
-It's a tragic tale.
-I said, do you have
any superstitions?
And you said, yeah, you have to
touch the plant
before you go out.
-I know.
-Because it's a giant --
-It is giant.
Before act two, at intermission,
I have to touch the plant's lips
with both hands.
I don't know how that started,
but now I really can't stop
doing it, yeah.
I thought I was being slick
about it too,
and I don't think I am.
I think everyone is like, "Why
are you rubbing on the plant?"
[ Laughter ]
-"I need good luck.
I need good luck on this."
Well, congrats.
It just got extended, your run.
-Yeah.
-This is going until April 30th.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-You were telling me that one of
your costars really is demanding
to be on the show here tonight.
-Yeah.
And I have to say yes.
I mean, is she back there?
[ Drum roll ]
Audrey II?
Come on out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be careful.
-Oh, my God.
-That's right, Jimmy, it's
Audrey II's time to shine.
It's my turn, Maude.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Audrey II, since you're here,
would you like to sing us
out to break?
-I thought you'd never ask.
Hit it, Roots.
♪♪
♪ If you want a rationale ♪
♪ It isn't very hard to see ♪
♪ Stop and think it over, pal ♪
♪ The guy sure looks like
plant food to me ♪
plant food to me! ♪
-Maude Apatow, Audrey II,
everybody!
Check out "Little Shop of
Horrors"
at the West Side Theater.
We'll be right back with
a performance
from Chance the Rapper.
Stick around.
-♪ If you want a rationale ♪
♪ It isn't very hard to see ♪
♪ Stop and think it over, pal ♪
♪ The guy sure looks like
plant food to me ♪
plant food to me! ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]